what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 breakdown video I just finished
watching episode 3 so let's discuss
everything that just happened and what
its going to lead to next the episode
starts on the beat to Dragonstone Jon
Snow was summoned by Daenerys Targaryen
from the advice of Melisandre which Jon
was happy to oblige because thanks to
Samwell Tarly he knows Dragonstone has a
ton of dragonglass that he's going to
need to use to make weapons to fight the
arming of the dead but jon is also there
to warn everyone about the threat beyond
the wall and in hopes of getting their
support for when the time comes to fight
the night king jon snow and davos
stepped foot on shore and are greeted by
tyrion lanister and missandei and as
most of you should know by now jon snow
and tyrion already had a history with
one another dating all the way back to
season 1 when they met in Winterfell and
traveled to the wall together when Jon
Snow decided he was going to join the
Nights Watch and I must say I do like
the way Jon and tyrion greeted each
other
tyrion calls John the bastard of
Winterfell and John calls Tyrion the
dwarf of Casterly Rock and it kind of
reminded me of when they first met when
they were both taking digs at each other
but a lot has changed since then they've
both been through hell and back
especially Jon Snow as Jon Snow and
Tyrion walked up to the castle on
Dragonstone something interesting
happened that some people might have
missed tyrion tells John that Starks
haven't fared well whenever they come
south but John said he's not a stark as
soon as John says he's not a stark the
dragon screeches and flies over their
heads which is just another nod to Jon
being at or garyun and having the blood
of a dragon as well as John and company
walk up to the castle Melisandre is
watching from above Varys greets her up
there and he's suspicious as to why she
isn't down there to greet him also
Melisandre didn't want to tell Varys
that she was exiled for burning princess
Shireen but she knows that she should
probably leave she tells him that her
job is done now that she has got nice
and fired together but I don't think
Melisandre is done just yet she said she
was going to leave Westeros and go to
volantis but you can't have a character
like this leave the plot in that way I
did hear the actress was pregnant so
that could be why they're having her
leave the show for now without actually
killing her off so we might actually see
Melisandre again her and Arya need to
see each other
and just like she promised cuz I think
she still has a part to play even if
it's being killed by someone she could
leave the show in a much better way in
my opinion and she also told John that
she could help him against the night
king right before she left Winterfell
and I'd like to see what else she has up
her sleeve but let's move on since
Tyrion feels like he knows and trusts
Jon Snow he was looking forward to him
arriving because this is one person he
can work with and hopefully come to some
sort of terms with but Jon was met with
some resistance Daenerys was expecting
John to come and bend a knee and swear
fealty to her she even made a reference
to their family being allies a long time
ago when Aegon Targaryen was conquering
the Seven Kingdoms with his three
dragons he got torn start to bend the
knee to him and no men had to lose their
lives on the field of battle that day so
Daenerys was hoping John was showing up
to do the same thing but John was not he
has plans of his own Daenerys says that
the oath torn Stark made to Aegon was
forever for life
but John refused to bend the knee still
John started to get a little bit
aggressive as well and he lets Daenerys
know that her father the Mad King
murdered members of his family Daenerys
does apologize for what her father did
she doesn't want to be judged by the
atrocities of her ancestors but little
do they know those are John's ancestors
as well
Daenerys says that she is the last
Targaryen but we all know she is not the
last Targaryen she's actually speaking
to her nephew right now John lets her
know that she will need his help
but she thinks since she has dragons in
the Dothraki she's just fine on her own
but she has no idea what lies beyond the
wall and the Lannisters are starting to
get some victories over her already
which is going to eventually put
Daenerys in a position to need John's
help down south sooner than she thinks
unless of course Cersei would decide to
help with the war against the army of
the Dead
but that's highly unlikely right now but
basically to sum everything up in this
scene there was a lot of tension between
John and Daenerys right now because she
wants everyone to kneel to her while she
claims the Seven Kingdoms as her own but
John doesn't have time for the politics
he needs all the dragonglass he can get
then he needs every single soldier in
the realm fighting up north against the
others John and Daenerys need each other
and they will both come to realise
this very soon who I guess John already
knows he needs to Marisa our dragons but
Danny will realize she needs John just
as much
Daenerys can stay in role the seven
kingdoms all she wants but she's going
to be rolling over a graveyard if she
doesn't do something about the dead that
are marching to the wall but she doesn't
believe in grumpkins and snarks just
like everyone else who hasn't seen them
for themselves but Tyrion doesn't
believe John Tyrion tells John that he
trusts the eye of an honest man while
Jon and Daenerys are playing tug of war
Davos brings up Jon's resurrection but
Jon quickly dismisses it almost as if
he's embarrassed by it John doesn't want
people to know this but Daenerys did
hear what Davos said and she even asked
hearing about it later
Daenerys tells John that he could be
warden of the north if he bends the knee
but you know John has to be thinking I'm
already king in the north
why would I take a pay cut but until
John bends the knee the North is seen as
being an open rebellion in John and
Davos aren't going anywhere but Varys
comes in and whispers and Daenerys is
here she finds out her allies were just
wiped out at sea she offers them bed and
breakfast then leaves the room in the
next scene Theon Greyjoy is rescued from
the sea after the devastating attack by
Euron Greyjoy feelin left his sister to
be taken prisoner as he fled the scene
of the crime
Theon is rescued by some other Ironborn
men and they aren't happy but not a
whole lot is said in this scene so let's
go to the next one where we see exactly
what happened with Yara and the
surviving sand snakes your own Greyjoy
has them in King's Landing tied up
behind him on his horse as he is greeted
with the parade of cheers they woke him
him and his new gifts for Cersei you're
on is so excited that the crowd is
cheering for him like this he taunts
Yara the entire time and I got to be
honest I feel bad for her I really don't
want to see Yara get tortured but until
someone comes to save her she's pretty
much screwed right now we see you're on
gallivant right to the Great Hall and
trots his horse all the way up to the
throne
just like Tywin did years ago Euron
showed up looking like a boss and his
ego is the size of the wall right now he
presents Cersei with her gifts and it's
very obvious she is furious you can see
the water filling up in her eyes as she
stares a hole through the sand snakes
the neuron starts to taunt Jaime he says
he is given Cersei what no other
and could which is justice for her
daughter Marcella but he wants to be
rewarded he wants Circe's hand in
marriage and she kind of agrees she says
he can had whatever he wants but after
the war is won Cersei has the sand
snakes down in the dungeon and I think
it's pretty obvious what's going to
happen next sir she's wearing the
brightest lipstick I've ever seen so it
should have been apparent in what she
was going to do next she taunts and
threatens ilaria but taim is the one who
gets it the worst she's given the kiss
of death I should say but it's going to
be a very slow and painful death
Cersei even says to make sure that the
torches are constantly changed every few
hours so ilaria can watch her daughter
suffer at all times and I got to be
honest I can't blame Cersei for doing
this Lauria did kill her daughter
some might say Cersei had it coming but
a Lauria had it coming also they haven't
shown what's going to happen - you're a
Greyjoy just yet so I think that leaves
the door open for at least some kind of
rescue attempt and I hope it's done by
fian hopefully he can put together some
kind of team to get in there and get her
out or perhaps Daenerys could do some
kind of negotiation and get her back in
that way but we're gonna have to wait
and see
Cersei is becoming the master and
Tycho's from the iron bank even says she
is turning into her father Tywin and I
bet that made Cersei very happy Cersei
is kind of feeling invincible right now
they might have lost Casterly Rock but
they are claiming some bigger wins
now that Cersei is Queen she gives zero
[ __ ] she doesn't even care if people
know she is sleeping with Jaime and she
even tells the maid to change the bed
sheets just in case it wasn't clear
enough that her and Jaime just had sex I
think it's safe to say Cersei is
enjoying her time as Queen and she
flexes her muscles once again in the
very next scene when she meets with the
bank to discuss the Crown's unpaid loans
and the iron bank is kind of acting like
they haven't decided yet who to back but
Cersei calls door bluff and says are you
really going to trust slaves into the
frackie to pay back your money
but they know the vaults are dry and the
Tyrells do have the money right now and
they are no longer allies with the
Lannisters at the moment but Cersei
offers him bed and breakfast and
promises she will have the money before
he leaves we then get a private scene
with John and Tyrion and John says he
kind of feels like he's a prisoner there
but tearing and says he's not even
though John's boat was seized tyrion
just kind of brushes that off - Antarian
cracks a joke and says John looks better
at birding than him but John isn't
really in the mood to joke he just wants
to know if he's going to have the
support when the time comes to fight the
dead he doesn't think Tyrion believes
him although Tyrion says he does cherry
and reminds John that he shouldn't give
up so easily in Tyrion said something
here that I really liked
Tyrion says Daenerys protects people
from monsters just like John does I
thought that was a cool line of dialogue
between them to Terry and ends up
talking Daenerys and I letting John mine
for dragonglass and he does make a good
point she isn't using it for anything so
just let him have it it could be a good
sign of faith and you may possibly get
something in return
Daenerys and John then have a private
conversation outside overlooking a beach
she tells John that he can mine for the
dragonglass and she will provide him
with men if he needs them which is a
good sign that they may be able to work
together after all as John walks away
she does glance back at him which is
most likely another sign that she might
have an attraction to him but that's to
be continued then we finally go to
Winterfell next and I got to admit
Shaun's it is taking care of business
she makes arrangements for food knowing
that everyone might have to shack up
there for the long winter as she has
walking around the courtyard watching as
the armor gets made Littlefinger ends up
stepping in and he continues to work his
way back into songs his head and he even
delivers his line that we heard in the
trailer but then we get interrupted by
someone arriving at the gate bran Stark
has finally made it back home and it
felt really good to see him there we
haven't seen much of a relationship at
all between songs and brain in the show
but just given what they had both been
through it felt really good to see these
two Starks reconnect they go out into
the gods wouldn't have a private
conversation songs of wishes that John
was here to see him - and brain says he
needs to speak with John and that did
get me excited because we all know brain
is sitting on a ticking time bomb right
now knowing the truth of John's lineage
but not only that brain can tell him
everything that he knows about the night
king and I can't wait for John and bran
to reconnect also because when they do
they're going to set the stage for the
actual end game of this series together
I think these two will be able to bring
down the army of the
and the night king but for now Fran must
continue to learn and see things better
he told Songza that he has seen
everything but it's only fragments bits
and pieces he can't quite put the full
picture together just yet but he will
learn to Sansa doesn't quite understand
what brain is saying she has never heard
the term the three-eyed Raven before and
brains demeanor has changed since he
spent his time beyond the wall and
seeing the things that he has seen bran
knows exactly what is coming he has seen
the army of the dead so I totally
understand why he seemed so distant
right now he then tells songs that he is
sorry for what happened to her right
there in her home he saw the abuse
Ramsay was putting her through and this
scare songs a little bit and she walks
away thinking what the [ __ ] just
happened she doesn't understand what
bran has become in his role for the end
game but she will learn soon enough next
we see Jorah Mormont getting a physical
from the maester thanks to Sam Jorah has
been cleared to leave the Citadel they
no longer need him they're taking up
space that another sick person can
utilize things are moving along pretty
quickly I was expecting Sam to get in
some kind of trouble for this for
putting himself and others at risk but
the archmaester told Sam he should be
proud he did something that other
maesters died trying to do and all Sam
said he did was follow the damn
instructions which was kind of funny he
kept it so simple Sam's next job is to
make copies of a bunch of old
manuscripts that they have lying around
the paper is so old it's actually
starting to deteriorate and you know
damn well he's going to find something
hidden in the stack of papers something
about John's parents the long nights
Valyrian steel or something I think this
is a little bit of foreshadowing that
Sam's going to discover something pretty
explosive next but I think we get some
more foreshadowing in the next scene to
Daenerys more or less says she is
unstoppable since she has these dragons
and I think that's going to come back to
bite her right in her eyes something's
going to happen to at least one of these
dragons
Tyrion then starts to describe Casterly
Rock and I swear this part of the
episode seemed like it was filmed by a
Quentin Tarantino Tyrion talks about
Casterly Rock having impregnable gates
and he talks about Cersei knowing
they're coming and he thinks they're
going to be outnumbered and as he's
describing this we actually see the
unsullied getting killed but that's not
actually what is happening what is
really happening is the unsullied are
about
enter through a secret passage that
Tyrion used to sneak his [ __ ] into and
they will catch them by surprise but
little does Tyrion know the bulk of the
Lannister men have been taken out of
there and moved to Highgarden as of
right now they're actually taking a
pretty much a worthless castle at the
moment and not only that but you're on
Greyjoy somehow made it all the way
around Westeros in time to destroy their
fleet while they are taking an empty
castle and while this is going on the
Lannisters are getting a big win Jaime
bran in the Tarly sack Highgarden for
their food in gold the Lannisters are
beating Daenerys on the score board
pretty bad right now and it's actually
kind of sad Cersei Jaime and Euron are
proving to be a tougher opponent than
they originally thought Daenerys
Targaryen three biggest alliances are
now out of the game the Greyjoy's the
Tyrells andice and snakes are finished
in Cersei now has the gold to pay off
the iron bank and get even more soldiers
on her side she has enough gold to hire
her own sell sword army now but this is
all setting the stage for the big war
that's to come in the very next episode
the spoils of war will be an absolute
bloodbath so far we've only seen three
quick battles with your owns being the
best but the next episode should be one
of the best battles Game of Thrones has
ever produced but before that happens
there is one last seen in this episode
after Jaime bran Randall and dicken
Tarly plus the rest of the Lannister
soldiers sack Highgarden Jaime confronts
Lady Olenna inside the castle and sadly
laney Olenna knows that her time is up
and I got to be honest with you I love
Lady Alanna she has been an awesome
character since the very beginning of
her role she is the toughest and one of
the smartest female characters in the
show and I love that we also got a call
back to Robb Stark in this scene also
Jaime basically took the same approach
Robb Stark did when he took Jaime
prisoner and it paid off for him also
Jaime did learn from his mistakes
Robb Stark sacrificed 2,000 men but he
ended up getting Jaime Lannister as his
prisoner and Jaime Lannister basically
just sacrificed Casterly Rock
but he got Highgarden instead with
enough food and gold to put them in a
very good position but I don't know if
that gold is ever going to make it back
to King's Landing
once the NARAS Targaryen finds this out
she must react and we've already seen
enough footage from the trailers and
promos to know that she strikes hard and
fast with a very large dragon and some
very pissed-off and bloodthirsty
Dothraki men who are just looking for a
good fight but before Jamie leaves
Highgarden alehna knows she must die
Cersei wanted her to be flayed and
strung up in King's Landing but
thankfully Jaime talked her out of that
Jamie hands her some poison that he says
is going to be painless
so lady Elena washes it down quick and
gets it over with she does know she's
kind of being shown some mercy right now
but she isn't going to go down without
one last prick from the Queen of thorns
she reveals to Jamie that she played a
big part in Joffrey's death and she
doesn't feel bad about that at all and
this does piss Jamie off any storms out
of the room as the rains of castamere
plays in the back the Lannisters may
have one now but not before the Queen of
thorns can give them one last [ __ ] you
before she exits the game I love that a
lot but how did you all feel about this
episode what did you like what did you
hate comment down below with your
thoughts and questions because I'd love
to hear them and I will be making my
breakdown for the preview teaser next
for episode 4 which I will release on
Tuesday then I'm thinking about live
streaming again on Wednesday evening so
hopefully all of you can make it if
you're not subscribed already you can
click that subscribe button then you can
click that notification bell if you want
so you can be notified every time I'll
release something new or go live thanks
for stopping by and watching today's
breakdown I do really appreciate that
and I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters as well that really
does mean a lot to me and I hope you all
have a good day
I'll see you down in the comment section
bye